hello um you cited a list of statistics
in your
talk which you claim support the idea
that illegal immigrants are dangerous
or criminals i'm i cited a number of
statistics that show that they commit
federal crimes at a significantly higher
rate than native born americans yeah
okay
so what role do you think that
structural racism
and inherent bias has to play in those
statistics
i don't think that the people who enter
this country illegally are forced
to do so by some sort of systemic racism
there's no systemic american racist
going down to el salvador and saying you
better get up and sneak into the united
states
and there's nobody in the united states
who forces people who come here
illegally to commit crimes i think the
premise of this question
is actually quite offensive though it's
a popular
assumption which is that illegal aliens
somehow don't have free will
it's the assumption that illegal aliens
are somehow morally
uh uneducated they have no sense of
right and wrong they have no ability
to control their their emotions and
their impulses this is
obviously profoundly racist and not true
we have free will we have the ability to
do what we want
to do this is why by the way the
majority of
hispanic hispanic people in the united
states
and hispanic voters oppose illegal
immigration
the races are exactly the same the
ethnicity is exactly the same the
question
of crime is different because race does
not determine your criminality
that's not what i'm saying i'm saying
that people of color are more likely to
be convicted of crimes unfairly
than white people they're more likely to
commit certain crimes that's
true i don't think that's because of
their race i think it's because
of aspects of their free will and
perhaps of culture
that that's not true i'm talking about
that is true i mean what i just said is
true
i'm not quite sure where you're getting
your statistics from and you choose from
the federal
government you choose to interpret them
in your bureau of justice statistics
department of homeland security well you
you said you didn't know where i got my
statistics from and i'm telling you
where i get them from
well it would have been nice if you
could have let me finish my sentence
anyway
i was answering your question
you are using your statistics for your
own political agenda
and that's i'm citing statistics because
they're true
i'm talking about the fact that i'm i'm
faculty here i also support our support
uh
um protester in the back what do you
support specifically do you
do you think that anti-immigrant
rhetoric is
violent free speech yes because you
think that speech is violence
uh no i think that's what that sign says
the conversation that you're having is
oppressive
um and so i am oppressing people by what
i'm doing i am
i am exerting violence on people by my
speech that's what the sign says
and that's what you just said it
contributes to and the protester is
saying that's exactly what i'm doing and
she's saying that's exactly what her
sign means so that means that you
a faculty member at an american public
university
paid for by taxpayer dollars are
conflating
speech with violence
yes um speech can be violent what you
are saying contributes to systemic
racism in this country
it means that my students of color are
pulled over and accused of stealing a
car when they did not
i'm not pulling anybody over for
stealing any cars i see many people of
many different races in this room i i
they all seem to be doing just fine i
don't think
i any any of them have felt violence
because they listened to a lecture on
on basic facts about our immigration
system
the question was have i asked people in
this room if they've felt
as though some violence has been
committed on them no i haven't asked
because no violence has been committed
on you
because violence is not a subjective
feeling violence is an
objective fact i can objectively gauge
whether or not
someone has become violent the other day
i was at the university of
missouri-kansas city
some protester attacked me with some
weird chemical that was an
objective act of violence but somebody
disagreeing with me
such as some people in this room are
doing are not committing violence on me
and i would say to you as a faculty
member at a taxpayer-funded university
this is the foundation of liberal
education
if you cannot understand that there is a
difference between speech
and violence you don't understand
anything that undergirds
the liberal arts or liberal education
and that is a real shame
and i say this with all respect and with
great distress
for our universities if our teachers
don't understand the difference between
ideas and violence
between speech and violence then they
are in no position to educate the next
generation
of americans
[Applause]
i've been to art school for eight years
i understand liberal arts extremely well
i am an artist
and i don't think you do i'm sure you've
been to art school for eight years but
you do not understand
the sign which says disrupting speech is
fascism you are no no the sign
says oh that one disrupting species
yes these people who are yelling are
disrupting my speech and i agree it's
fascism
[Applause]
you're interrupting me and i think that
you need to look up violence in the
dictatory or and expand your idea of
violence
hold on i'll look it up right now hold
on hold on a second let me look it up
let's see violence definition hold on
violence definition so you're saying
that
that violence can be a speech oh my
wi-fi went out that's too bad i'll look
it up later i'll post it on my twitter
violence is not speech let me say it
again
violence is not speech let me say it for
all the professors in the room
violence is not speech speech is not
violence